nantes châteaubourg gonds un aéroport
qui existent situé près de la ville
assez bien aménagé mais un peu bruyant
et bientôt trois petits
à 20 kilomètres au nord de nantes la
campagne des communes paisible une zone
agricole où l'élevage marche bien où les
agriculteurs sont assez prospère
on aurait pu remplacer château bourgon
par un grand aéroport situé entre rennes
et nantes pour desservir tout l'ouest
on a choisi le site de notre dame des
landes vigneux-de-bretagne grand champ
est très fière sur cette zone on
aménagera peut-être à l'avenir en
aéroport ouest atlantique
s'il est intéressante vis-à-vis de
nantes
elle est aussi intéressante vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble des villes de l'ouest
dans la mesure où on peut penser que à
partir de 1990 par exemple 1980 c'est
d'ailleurs aux drogues pourra servir à
des liaisons beaucoup plus lointaine
alors à ce moment là on a calculé par un
certain nombre de procédés sur lequel
nous nous étendrons pas que la situation
de notre dame des landes était
relativement proche de ce qu'on peut
appeler le centre de gravité de
l'ensemble des grandes villes de l'ouest
la position de la mairie péter notre
dame des landes
nous avons pris une délibération en date
du 29 septembre 72 et nous avions émis
un avis favorable
la décision n'a pas été facile à prendre
le conseil municipal de notre dame des
landes manquer d'éléments de jugement il
a suivi l'avis favorable donné par les
autres communes situées sur la zone et
en particulier vigneux de bretagne
des réserves ont été émises par les élus
locaux par souci de protéger des
agriculteurs et aussi les riverains du
futur aéroport
dans un premier temps le préfet de
région a signé la création de la zone où
sera situé l'aéroport la zad monsieur
guillard explique pourquoi il y était
favorable
pourquoi on demandé et bien parce que
nous avons pensé puisque une zad dur
quand même 14 ans alors pendant les
quatorze années
quand le décret de zad ou l'arrêter à de
sapri car sur le préfet de
loire-atlantique préfet de région les
agriculteurs concernés ans quand même 14
ans pour soit se reconvertir ouvert
leurs positions ou votre maison ne sera
pas sur la zone de l'aérodrome votre
maison là ici à n'ont peut-être pas plus
haut ça passe au dessus et grenoble et
qu'est ce que ça vous fait vous de
savoir qu'il y aura des dromes ici alors
on aurait tant aimé porte mais qu'est ce
qui va se passer pour vous de partir
pour partir chercher un autre notre
endroit pour habiter et où est ce que
vous pensez à les milieux parce qu'on
est originaire de vie n'est pas très
loin de toute façon ao non alors qu'on a
on aimerait c'est pour les enfants ça
fait plus tant pour les enfants que pour
nous mêmes
17 exploitations se trouve sur la zone
les agriculteurs ils sont jeunes deux
sur trois en moins de 50 ans un comité
de défense des riverains a été créé il
se demande si l'aéroport serait
justifiée avec une crise de l'énergie il
retraite aussi que des routes
départementales soit supprimé a joué les
raisons qui poussent à faire cet
aéroport sont d'intérêt régional plus
que local c'était en dram devraient
prendre leur emplacement entérineront
drôme de châteaubourg lequel peut se
développer encore avec les éléments
actuels jusqu'au environ 290 sans trop
de difficultés mais à partir de même de
1990 en raison d'une part de l'extension
du trafic et en raison d'autres par des
nuisances dégagée par ce trafic sur
l'agglomération nantaise il notamment
sur la partie sud ouest de
l'agglomération nantaise
il sera nécessaire de déplacer
l'aéroport de trouver un site un peu
plus éloignés quoique suffisamment
proche permettant à la fois d'éviter des
nuisances et de permettre un trafic bien
plus considérables en escomptant 1985 un
préfixe de l'ordre de 1 million un
million trois cent mille passagers pour
se faire une idée de ce qu'est ce trafic
le temps type de lyon est actuellement
de l'ordre de 1 million de passagers est
exceptionnellement situé dans une zone
d'une part où l'urbanisation est très
faible et où d'autre part où la
direction des pistes d'envol qui sont à
peu près dans la direction des vents
dominants ce délire est ouest ne risque
pas d'importer govies ans sur des sur
des territoires où vraiment la danse
population est relativement faible
si vous êtes toujours là ça va vous
gênez vous croyez du coup vous ne
resterez pas quand j'entendrai le
vacarme moselle quand j'ai des frissons
pendant non sur le plan aviation
aéronautique est ce qu'on connaît les
zones de bruit de notre dame des landes
on t'a fait du futur aéroport
on les connaît il ya des zones type
effectivement oui mais tout dépend ces
zones sont directement fonction du
trafic ce qui fait qu on ne peut pas
déterminer longtemps l'avant ce nom une
courbe données sera toujours bonne mais
on peut pas dire à quelle échéance
mais parce que c'est important dans la
mesure où des gens voudraient par
exemple s'installer construire dans une
zone assez proche
si cela se trouve dans une zone trop
proche de l'aéroport
ils ne peuvent pas le faire oui mais
enfin je peux vous confirmer d'une parc
la zad est assez large justement été
conçue largement l'aérodrome lui-même ne
nécessiterait que 600 ou 650 hectares et
on en met le double dans la za justement
pour protéger aussi les voisins
l'aéroport ouest atlantique desservirait
tout l'ouest il assurerait un trafic
international
on y installerait une piste d'envol puis
deux et peut-être trois un jour en
fonction de l'évolution du trafic
château boudouin serait alors réservé à
l'aviation d'affaires
ce que vous en pensez des aérodromes
comme ça qui vient de se mettre à la
campagne engagée voulait il ya du
chômage
nous arrivons pouvoir en occuper la
domaine il ya du boulot à faire
c'est une porte ouverte pour l'avenir il
c'est une des portes ouvertes les plus
intéressantes à mon avis pour le
décollage de l'ensemble des français
on prendrait peut-être l'avions toujours
là là là je ne lui ai pas demandé
et dire que tu montes dans mon lit alors
un avion